every creature from a warm insect bird
plant tree everybody all of them are
trying to be full-fledged lives if one
sees what's happening beneath the in
terms of the root systems it is an
enormous effort for a plant or a tree to
become a full-fledged tree well an apple
tree is not trying to be an oak tree but
an apple tree wants to be a full-fledged
apple tree that effort is on in every
life so is it in human beings but the
problem with humanity is just this that
for every other creature nature has
drawn two lines within these two lines
they live and die so their idea of full
fledge is hitting the ceiling of their
life but if a human being hits a ceiling
he gets frustrated and miserable because
nature this process of evolution has
delivered to us to a place where there
is only the bottom line there is no top
line though some human beings are trying
to breach the bottom line and go below
that effort also is going on so
essentially what human life is when
life was in the other forms of life that
you see on the planet nature determined
a certain compulsive instinctive ways of
functioning once you become human these
lines have been removed you can act
consciously that means what you call as
human potential is not of any kind of
measurable limit it can go as far as you
desire or as far as you have the courage
to walk
so when we say human potential
unleashing human potential
it is not about reaching the peak
is a trajectory
because
what our life is
is a combination of a certain amount of
time and energy
time is rolling away for all of us at
the same pace if you sit it rolls away
if you sleep it rolls away if you do
something it goes away if you don't do
anything it goes away you're happy or
miserable it goes away
time is running out for all of us
so it's only the energy that you can
do different things with
if you bring your energies to a certain
level of intensity
and possibility
what somebody does in 10 years you may
do it in one year
this means if you live here for 100
years it feels like in people's impact
that you have created it feels like you
lived here for a thousand years
simply because
you have managed your life energies in a
certain way
so for me
a human being being impactful means
how conscious have you become this is
very important
because if you're in compulsive cycles
then your energy gets wasted in so many
things
if you observe people
in a day let's say let's take 24 hours
in that anyway most people by
prescription in america they sleep for
eight hours
[Laughter]
so eight hours means one third of life
is gone
in the remaining two thirds they have to
eat they have to you know shower
bathroom this that all this another two
three hours gone
so literally fifty percent
of life is gone daily basis just for
basic maintenance of this life
fifty percent of the time is gone in
maintenance remaining fifty percent what
they have
if you look at every single move that
they may make with their body their
thought process their emotions
you will see a whole lot of it is
happening in compulsive cycles
or in other words
if you are a little sensitive to life
you will realize you are the biggest
issue in your life
so this is one thing
that i'm trying to do with people that
you are never the issue in your life
i'm not the issue my thought my emotion
my body is never the issue
my thought my emotion my energy and my
body are my instruments of function they
are not impediments in my life
but i would say for 90 of the human
beings their own body
then the compulsions of the body the
compulsions of their thought the
compulsions of their emotions
are ruling them most of the time
need motivation watch your top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because chances
are you
are the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
sad guru and my take on his top 10 rules
for success enjoy
rule number two be perceptive perception
happens to you in five different
dimensions
seeing hearing smelling tasting touching
this is how you're perceiving life
this data data has gathered within you
only because this data has gathered
within you now you're able to walk on a
round planet which spins it's not a
small thing
it is not a small thing that you are
able to walk on a spinning round ball
because all this data has gathered
through five senses it is not
intellectual information but it is a
perceptional information
if this information is not there you
won't be able to walk actually
you will not be able to walk straight
this is what is happening for people
when some people lose their memory and
things like that suddenly they become
unstable in their body because some of
the data is gotten disconnected with
their system
so
this data that you perceive is most
important that's what a child is all the
time drinking up everything you see how
the child is looking at everything
because he wants to drink up as much
data as possible because instinctively
he knows without the data he will not be
able to function
so how attentive you are
how attentive your eyes are how
attentive your ears nose tongue and
touch ease accordingly you have that
much you know that much
usable information so why one person is
more efficient well you are an athlete
why one person is able to catch a damn
ball another person can't catch the damn
thing
why is it
because that level of attention of
exactly how that ball will behave how
you can anticipate where it will go this
is not there intellectually suppose you
have a phd in football you think you can
play football
uh
if you have a phd i no i think you need
to experience it as well if you just
study it only yeah
no that is that is not experience it's
perception you are you're watching it
out of your keen interest you're
watching exactly how a ball moves you
may not be thinking the physics of it
but you're watching it and perceiving it
because of that perception you know
something that you cannot know by
reading 100 books about it rule number
three
stay happy why does one person need uh
well by prescription these days
eight hours is it
seven seven to eight hours seven hours
sleep
okay seven hours
and why another person can do with half
of that
see one thing is
as we already went through the very
physical body that you carry is just the
food that you've eaten isn't it
you're looking at food only as a protein
vitamin mineral like this
but we're talking about
a food chain that means
they're all different kinds of lives
what we consume is another form of life
every animal consumes another form of
life this is the way the food cycle is
created
so in what condition that life is
will determine
in what condition your life is in many
ways
so your food appears in front of me if i
just look at it
people have prepared it with elaborate
care if i just look at it i said no
this is a no sad guru sadhguru this girl
this lady has brought it she's a very
good cook she's very tasty
i just look at it
simply because it's not alive enough for
me it may be tasty but it's not alive
enough for me
if it's not alive enough i will not
consume if you're just conscious of this
one thing
you will see your sleep quota will go
down
another thing is
most people are eating at least fifty
percent fifty percent means hundred
percent more than what they need to eat
yes you you will do one thing as an
experiment just try this whatever you
eating cut it down by fifty percent
if you're eating let's say uh two
kilograms of food cut it down to one
kilogram and eat variety of foods
you will see you will neither drop
weight
nor will you become weak nor will you
become less energetic only thing that
will happen is your sleep quota will go
down
because you're putting so much food to
generate the same same amount of energy
you're eating more by compulsion
of liking the taste or simply by
compulsion of filling yourself
up now the body has to press process so
much food to create so much energy
this extra processing is taking a toll
on the system
the amount of impurities that are there
in the food will also determine how
how much inertia you generate in the
body let's understand it this way in
terms of physical terms what sleep means
is inertia right now your dynamic this
is life
inertia satsang
when inertia goes beyond a certain point
that's death
but sleep is a certain kind of death
but it is offering you
rest
so restfulness is very important
what is being restful means is
if you sit here
if you are a total ease
you will see the body is naturally
restful if you have you noticed on a
particular day you are very happy
on that day you don't need much sleep or
food have you noticed this
that's all you have to do
if you remain very joyful every moment
of your life
the food will come down sleep will come
down naturally rule number four don't
multiply pain the notion of the
difference between pain and suffering i
thought was very useful
the pain is physiological it's there it
was no pain most people would not even
know how to protect themselves
see just because there's no pain in the
sea what all you've done to it
isn't it
see there's no pain in this so that's
why you
took it off if there's no pain in your
nose
maybe you would have taken it off
because the many advantages you will
take in about 22 extra oxygen if you
just remove this one thing contraption
[Laughter]
wherever there is no pain people are
messing with it like crazy isn't it they
call this hairstyle they call it so many
things yeah
suppose there was no pain in the entire
body in los angeles
people would pull out their stomach bag
and
you think they wouldn't do it no problem
only pain is helping them to preserve
themselves isn't it so pain is good
there's no physiological pain most
people would not know i hear in united
states there's one group they call
themselves something i forget that word
they're actually cutting their fingers
off their hands off on the video
wow they're posting it online
there's a group like that wow
can you imagine this no
in spite of so much pain if there was no
pain
almost everybody would have cut
themselves off in the name of fashion
they would have cut themselves into
ribbons
so pain is a good thing physically
because that is your
preservation self-preservation mechanism
but suffering is something that you do
in your mind
so pain that happens in your body you
take it in your mind and multiply it a
thousand times or a million times
depending on how capable you are
or how stupid you are
and suffer it a million times over
right now
most human beings are like this what
happened
10 years ago they can still suffer
what may happen day after tomorrow they
already suffer
they are not suffering life they think
they are suffering life they are not
suffering life they are suffering the
two most fantastic faculties that human
beings alone have
a vivid sense of memory and a fantastic
sense of imagination
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five learn from
people's mistakes i don't know i never
looked at life as a series of mistakes
learning from that i don't look at life
like that
well
have you done made some dumb decisions
here and there of course
but
i wouldn't see them as mistakes i just
see them as part of growing up
and
becoming more mature because
enlightenment is one thing you see
things clearly
but still operating in the world you
need wisdom wisdom you have to earn it
with experience there is simply no other
way for that today it has become
fashionable with all these management
gurus and all saying you must learn from
your mistakes you must learn
mistakes that means you must keep on
doing mistakes
i don't believe that you must learn from
your mistakes i would rather live a life
where i don't do any mistakes
because life is so brief you do a bunch
of mistakes and then you will learn and
where will you use it in the grave
of other people's mistakes yeah
yes of course that is what being human
means that we can learn from other
people's experience from history we can
learn we don't have to do all those
things once again and especially you are
from the aviation uh state
if you are trying aviation or if you're
trying skydiving or something
if you don't do things right the first
time
well that'll be the last time rule
number six live responsibly don't utter
the word freedom because freedom is a
consequence it's something that you have
to earn
it doesn't come as a philosophy in 60s
we thought it's a philosophy
if you live responsibly you will see
freedom will come when i say responsibly
not in the sense of civic responsibility
if you retain your ability to respond to
life
without any prejudice
without any restriction you will see you
will become free
your ability to respond
if it is unlimited it is freedom rule
number seven manage your energy there
are many aspects to this fundamentally
if you keep your life energies very
exuberant
now you will see the sleep quota will
naturally come down to keep it exuberant
you should not be overleading
largely in the ashram everybody young
people also eat only 2 meals a day 10 in
the morning 7 in the evening
our activity
exceeds most people's activity in the
world and we are 7 days 365 days we
don't know what's a vacation
because we're enjoying what we're doing
we don't want a break
so
they never go on a vacation there is no
break there's no sunday monday nonsense
nothing every day something is happening
endlessly
but you will see
people are very energetic healthy sleep
is very little
so energetically a human being can be at
different levels why this is important
is
see what we call as life is just a
combination of two things
a certain amount of energy and a certain
amount of time
when it comes to time
it is ticking away for all of us at the
same pace clock doesn't run slowly for
me faster for you there's no such
whether
thing
are busy you are lazy you are sleeping
you are doing useful things or useless
things it doesn't matter what you do or
you do not do
time is ticking away
so there is no such thing as time
management you can manage your energy
if you raise your energy to a higher
pitch of intensity
what somebody does in 10 years you may
do it in one year
so if you live for 100 years it looks
like you lived for a thousand years
simply because your energy is pitched up
this every human being can do
the whole yogic system is one dimension
of yogic system is just towards this if
you sit here even if you simply sit here
with your eyes closed you don't sit here
in a static way
you sit here in a dynamic way
you never become static because static
is called as death
if everything becomes static that is
death if inertia really sets in that is
death
so sleep in yoga is seen as death
you die every day
how long do you want to die in a day
you really must use this word for
yourself don't tell anybody i'm going to
die
for yourself how long do i want to die
in a day
eight hours a day if you die
one third of your life you're dead
in 24 hours eight hours you're dead
means one third of your life dead
another four hours goes into eating
sleeping eating toilet bath this that
where is the time to live i'm asking
so if life is precious the most
important thing to do is keep your
energies in an exuberant way so that
life becomes more life feels enhanced
because you cannot enhance time rule
number eight don't turn intelligence
against yourself one thing is
the survival processes become easier
than ever before
believe me in the morning if you need a
bucket full of water if you had to walk
a mile to the river to get one bucket of
water
and your family needed 25 buckets of
water
you would have no time to mess yourself
now you have a lot of time to mess
yourself because our survival is better
organized than ever before another thing
is most human beings do not know how to
manage their biochemistry without
physical activity
i have seen a whole lot of people
particularly
teenage boys and girls between the ages
of 12 and 16 who come to me with some
severe
violent problems within themselves
if you leave them like that they may
kill themselves or kill somebody else
they're in that kind of state
many of them have even killed their
parents you know it just happened all
over the world
and
in 2017 when i came to know
that in india
which is not so much suicidal in that
sense because there's a huge family
support and stuff like that in spite of
that
in 2017 18 600 children below 18 years
of age committed suicide
out of which 7200 are below 15 years of
age
so 12 13 14 year olds
who must be bubbling with life
are wanting to take their own lives why
obviously we're doing something
fundamentally wrong with the society
isn't it
yes our goals and our stupid ideas of
what is success is driving them nuts
[Music]
because we are trying to use our
children like racehorses that's
interesting
and when you say that as something to
that represent us that we've turned into
something amazing or in what way are
they like racehorses see when you
understand life as a race
if you're in a race what's the objective
you must reach the finish line quick
isn't it
yes what is the finish line of your life
death
there you have it
this may not be a conscious process but
life within you is understanding it like
that
when you see you must understand this
whether you are conscious of conscious
of it or not any human being
right now if you make yourself miserable
you must understand you are sending a
message to every cell in the body that i
don't want to live
you might not have articulated it in
your head yet
but when you become miserable you notice
suddenly your body seems heavy
and it's lack doesn't want to get up
from this chair
have you seen this yes
when you're happy
you're willing to bounce at everything
and do everything bend backwards if
necessary
why this is happening is the message is
gone to every cell in the body this guy
wants to die
they're all thinking okay what can we do
to help him but by then of course you
recover
so you want to die you want to live you
want to die you want to live
the body is getting confused
because you must understand this is a
very intelligent body it's taking
instructions from you
every cell in the body has enormous
sense of memory and intelligence
if you keep sending wrong messages
if they act you did
because you're sending contradictory
messages you're not dead you're half
dead
you can give it any number of exotic
names essentially you have turned your
intelligence against yourself
this is supposed to work for you but now
you've turned it against yourself it's
working against you rule number nine
liberate yourself first of all people
are assuming
that
anger is happening to them
or misery is happening to them no this
is exactly what i said earlier maybe i
didn't articulate it fully no you are
creating anger you're creating misery
you're creating joy you're creating
whatever all this is happening from
within you but human experience is
happening from within us isn't it right
whether it's love or hate or anger or
misery or joy or anything is only
happening from within us now simple
question i am asking is what happens
from within you
should you have should it happen your
way or somebody else's way
it should happen your way
of course because the world will never
happen your way 100
because there are so many stakeholders
in the world little bit will happen my
way a little bit your way that is fine
but what happens within me must happen
my way if what happens within me does
not happen my way this is the worst form
of slavery isn't it wow
somebody decides what happens within me
somebody decides where i should sit this
is slavery everybody understands this
now somebody decides whether i am happy
or unhappy isn't this the worst form of
slavery yeah
so this is the liberation that humanity
needs to work at this is what inner
engineering means inner engineering is
not some
mechanical process because engineering
means this essentially you will say
something is well engineered
only if it works the way you want isn't
it
if this one doesn't work the way you
want
what the hell are you expecting other
things to work the way you want it's
just an accident when you live
accidentally anxiety is normal and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is have fun he or
she is hot
now they say
you must see this one come here
come here come here
you wanna see how she's laughing at
every joke
[Applause]
she's cool
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week
put it down in the comments below and
i'm going to show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
see suppose
you want flowers in your garden
if you sit in your garden and everyday
do flower meditation
flowers will not come
if you want flowers you don't have to
even think about flowers you must think
soil manure water sunlight
soil doesn't feel like a flower
manure doesn't smell like a flower
water doesn't look like a flower
sunlight doesn't feel like a flower but
if you take care of these things flowers
will happen isn't it this is the way
life works
so the important thing with our lives is
this is a very westernized approach that
we are looking at the goal we want the
product
we don't want the
process no if you're devoted to the
process
if you're truly devoted to the process
that you're doing right now you will
naturally do your best everything that
you have
result will come or no
result will come on it'll come just
because you sit here and desire the
result it's not going to come
you will only have plastic flowers in
your head
flowers will not grow in your garden
it's time to understand
all the problems
of individual nature
are generated from within
and we don't have to solve problems that
we create
we just have to dissolve
problems that you create you don't have
to solve if there's a problem in the
situation yes we have to solve
but you have a problem within you
solution is not what you need solution
is madness
solution means for an illusion you're
creating an illusory solution
something that you make up
for that you create one more solution
that you made up once again no
you just have to turn off the problems
you're going through a certain drama
only thing is you're a lousy director
that's all there is
means of improving your direction
now you're trying to
find a solution for a situation in a
drama
it's like people watch a cinema and come
home and they have big arguments about
what happened there
so
the thoughts and emotions that you
create
you don't have to find any solution for
it
if you just turn it off it's gone
if you find solution
you
moving towards insanity
because
you create a ghost and you create a
ghostbuster
the ghost that you create
you must learn to play with them
hello
i'm saying if nobody willing to play
with you you have to play with somebody
right
so the ghosts you create if you like
them you play with them if you don't
like them turn them off
but guru they keep coming
you don't play
don't like to play with them don't play
they come and go never it ever happened
that one thought remained for more than
a moment isn't it
it comes and goes comes and goes let it
come and go
if you try to find a solution for that
i you will head towards
insanity you told the story of a man who
had wings but never used them to fly and
just reproduce and had a life and isn't
a tragedy that he
never use his wings to fly
do you feel like most of us are walking
through life with wings and we never use
them to fly unfortunately yes a whole
lot of people too many people
it's time
that human potential is unleashed
because we are the first generation on
the planet
for whom our survival is organized
better than ever before ever
so this is the time to unlock our
potential to lose those
all kinds of inhibitions and fears
that we had there was a time
if as much as a cloud gathered and
lightning and thunder happened we
thought god was angry with us right okay
all those things are gone
it is time you take away the nonsense
that's happening within you
and
the entire process the science of inner
engineering is just this
how to work at it
in a scientific manner
not with philosophy i can tell you a
thousand times give up your fear it's
not going to go
but
if your chemical soup is blissful
there's not even a
idea of fear in your mind
[Music]
it reminds me of your concept of the
movies you play the movies in your mind
you can choose a drama you can choose a
horror story or you can choose
a positive movie
and not get stuck in the same movie
forever we can turn it off and start a
new one
yeah but for that you should know where
the
switches are right
you are
like a super computer
but you haven't found the keyboard yet
time to find the keyboard that's my work
to give people the keyboard to their
supercomputer see the reason the only
reason a human being
will seek to know something is because
he realizes that he does not know
if he does not realize that he does not
know
there will be no longing to know
there will be no seeking to know and
definitely there will be no knowing
it's not possible whether it is
spiritual seeking or any other kind of
knowledge
you will seek only because you realize
you do not know
if you think you know everything or you
believe you know everything
you will be just too full of yourself
that's all
and that is a huge problem that's a very
big problem
uh though we have a culturally
cultivated humility that you see all
over the place everybody is like this
only but still too full of yourself when
you bend nothing goes out of your head
one thing that you must do to yourself
is
you are absolutely truthful to yourself
if you're also truthful to everybody
around you
you will get other kinds of benefits
with people
but
i will not go that far right now
with yourself
you are 100 truthful
otherwise
all kinds of tricks keep happening
to be truthful to yourself
is not a easy thing because
there is
lifetimes of habit
of simply bullshitting yourself a guest
came to shankaranpula's house
and being a south indian man down south
you know
pillai's come from further down south
he was carrying an umbrella which is
common thing
in kerala and southern
tamil nadu to carry an umbrella is a
very common thing because
reigns can
be very heavy
then they walked out he took the guest
out then it started raining
the shangri-la did not open
the umbrella the guest said why don't
you open the umbrella
saying grandpa i said
i'm sorry the umbrella is full of holes
then the guest asked why did you bring
it
well i never thought it will rain today
a whole lot of people are like this
they think somebody else has to catch
their lives
this will take a long time
because
someone else catching your lies
will take lifetimes
you must catch them
you should not let your chickens pass
to become 100
straight with yourself
you take a certain amount of application
but
if this one thing you do as a tomah
this piece of life will work for sure
100
then figuring out a few things is very
simple
for that i am there
if you just fix one this this one thing
that you are 100 straight
no any kind of deception
when there's a hole in the umbrella you
know there is a hole in the umbrella
you will never forget that there is a
hole in the umbrella okay
if you are like this
rest of the work becomes very simple and
easy people are always thinking that
something else or somebody else is
restricting their freedom
but once freedom is lost simply because
they are tangled up with their own body
and their own mind
these are two dimensions of you two
faculties
unless
your body and your mind
is fully in your hands
if they're continuously working for you
never against you
only then you can live a successful life
people have approached inner well-being
either with belief systems or
philosophies or ideologies or some wacky
ideas of their own
it's time to approach your inner
well-being in a scientific manner
as the science and technology to create
external well-being
there is a whole science and technology
to create inner well-being
that is what we call as calling as inner
engineering technologies for well-being
it is time that you approach your inner
well-being also
in a
scientific systematic way
and employ technologies to create this
well-being everything else you're using
technology you understand
that
technology can facilitate everything on
the outside
why don't you understand
that
the best piece of technology on this
planet is this human mechanism
unless you approach it properly it will
not heal
living here is half a human being is not
good enough
right now people's idea of success is
they're doing better than their neighbor
now your idea of success should be that
you are a full-fledged life because
this is not my idea this is not my
philosophy
this is the longing of every life
every worm insect bird tree animal and
also a human being
are always striving to become a
full-fledged life spiritual process
means to become like a mountain
stable still
because
it's
only when somebody has a very stable
base
many things can be done
exuberance of life is possible
only if there is absolute stability
otherwise exuberance will lead to
madness
yes
that's why a lot of people who are a
little creative little active little
exuberant
always end up being freaky and
nearly insane
because without stability
you cannot
have a dance going
this is why
shiva means stillness shiva means dance
at the same time
either you see him sitting absolutely
still
or you see him in an explosion of dance
because an explosion is possible only
when there is a stable base
an explosion
which is not destructive is possible
only when there is stability
and stability
people try to become stable by
controlling and trimming their lives
this is the way your grandmother would
tell you how to be stable control
yourself
then you will be stable yes if you're
dead you will be stable
i promise you that
so normally people who talk about
stability are all
[Music]
constipated existence
you know what's constipation
that means it happens little by little
[Music]
their joy their love their ecstasy
happens little by little here and there
that's constipation
so
stability is not because you have
trimmed your life down
or pruned it down to minimal and you're
stable
that's of no
consequence
stability because you see everything
utterly clearly
that is why
when we say adi yogi we're talking about
stability
at the same time an exuberant dance
this is possible only because he has
more than two eyes
not necessarily three
more than two that means he sees much
more than most people ever see
because he sees much much more
able to be stable stability it takes
to allow exuberance to happen otherwise
you keep curtailing your exuberance
because it hurts when it's out of
balance
if you're out of balance and you move at
a certain speed you're going to hurt
yourself
whether you're riding a bicycle
or you're riding the cosmos
if you're out of balance and you attain
speed you're going to hurt yourself very
badly
so balance
is very important and balance that comes
out of curtailment is not balanced
that's
you know
packaged death so you must understand
this
if everything that you try to do is
becoming frictious
friction is happening
obviously
you are the sandpaper
you know what's a sandpaper
i'll ask them to provide you a sandpaper
a small piece
every day whenever you have a friction
with somebody just
scrape your skin somewhere
so if you don't cure yourself quickly
you won't have any skin left
when you don't have any skin left
then you will not touch anything
you will not create you will not look
for any friction
you will walk in suppose you had no skin
how would you walk
even a little
feather won't touch you like that you
will walk isn't it because everything
hurts now
so if you want that kind of treatment we
can do
otherwise first come to your senses
friction is happening means
wherever you go friction is happening
obviously
one simple thing you can do to reduce
friction is i've told you many times but
you've not done this is
whatever you're saying
in a day
or in an hour
or in a minute
how many words per minute are you
uttering bring it down to 50 percent
still do the same work you will see a
whole lot of friction will go down
simply because you're not blabbering
yes
and
we've been trying to train you
whatever you see whether you see a man
woman child
cow donkey
donkey also
no
how will friction not happen it will
happen
so
only when satguru is here like this rest
of the time like this it won't work
bring this into you not just as a
symbolism genuinely
so
friction
of two kinds one within ourselves
outside is just an expression and a
consequence
so
this whole thing about inner engineering
means just this
that when you sit here you can sit here
without any friction
if you can sit here without any friction
outside friction also will go down
but when you meet a sandpaper there must
be some friction
there are sandpapers
hello
so when you meet a sense paper there
must be friction
otherwise how there will be
so generally we avoid sand paper if we
can but sometimes we have to work with
them
when we have to work with the sand paper
you need tact
this is something you have to learn this
will not come
this is not nothing spiritual about it
this is
tact in the society
sometimes it doesn't work but it's a
question of skill
some people who are not spiritual in any
way
they are very tactful when they meet
sand papers
you will see this kind of agents and
others who are working in government
offices and in political atmospheres
they are so smooth it doesn't matter how
rough the other person is these people
just
they'll just get their job done and
leave
so working with sandpaper
takes a little bit of skill and
experience
nothing spiritual about it it's a social
skill
but uh generally
in the ashram
very few sand papers once in a way
people pop up sand on them but they drop
it you know they don't keep it all the
time sometimes
sometimes they're like that
they're not like that all the time
so when they are like that when the
porcupine has its
thing up you must just keep away
a bit
when it's down you can talk to it
it doesn't keep it up all the time
it doesn't have the strength to do that
so
your friction
you must understand it's just you on a
certain day
a bull and a pheasant were grazing
bull was chomping the grass pheasant was
picking off picking ticks off the bull
partnership the huge tree at the edge of
the field the pheasant very
nostalgically looked at the tree and
said oh alas there was a time i could
fly to the topmost branch of the tree
now i do not have enough strength in my
wing even to get to the first branch
the bull very nonchalantly said that's
no issue
just eat a little bit of my dung every
day
within a fortnight you'll get there
pheasant said come on what kind of
rubbish is that
the bull said really try and see the
whole humanities on it
so very hesitantly the pheasant started
pecking at the dung
and lo on the very first day it reached
the first branch of the tree
within a fortnight it reached the
topmost branch of the tree
just beginning to enjoy the scenery
an old farmer was rocking on his rocking
chair saw a fat old pheasant sitting on
top of the tree pulled out his shotgun
and shot the bird off the tree
the moral of the story is
many times even
can get you to the top but it never lets
you stay there if you're postponing
something
you're obviously doing something that
you don't want to do
if there is something that you really
want to do will you postpone it or prep
on it
hello
do you see somebody is waiting for
someone they badly want to see
only 10 minutes
in the 10 minutes they will look at the
watch 25 times
why they want to prep on it
you're doing something that you don't
want to do so you want to postpone it
i'm asking why the hell are you doing
something that you don't want to do
no because if i do this i will get that
i will get that
that's not the point
there's nothing to get in this life
there's really nothing to get in this
life
either you lived this life in a profound
and intense manner or you did not
what will you get in the end
if somebody dies in the agricultural
college do they bury them or
fire them
how is it what's a tradition
burying is good for agriculture
because human beings make good manure
so in the end what will happen to you
and me
they will either bury us or burn us
that's all will happen in the end you
think something else they'll give you a
price
nothing will happen in the end
only thing is the process of life how
wonderfully did you live
that's all there is
so if you are doing something really
wonderful
do you want to prepon it or postpone it
pre-born only so you must find
what is it that you really want to do if
you find that one thing you will always
prepone everything not postponed this
happened in 1941
this is just when the nazi
movement was building up in germany and
in some parts of europe
so one day in austria
a bunch of german soldiers came broke
into the homes
the jewish family a rich family they
broke the home
and took away the adults took everything
was robbed
and these two children a 12 year old
girl and an eight-year-old boy were
taken away they were taken to a railway
station
this is the month of november and
december kind of time
when it's becoming very cold
so they were kept in the railway station
for three days because the trains did
not come boys little boys being boys
they started playing football
so they were playing football and
then suddenly the train came
the train is not a passenger train it's
a
cargo train a good stream
so when the train came the soldiers came
and rushed everybody into the
wagons which are there
everybody got in and the little boy and
the girl also got in but the little boy
forgot to wear his shoes
he left his shoes outside
and they pushed him into the wagon so
without shoes he came
his
sister a 12 year old girl
saw her kid brother coming without shoes
and she got mad with him she held him by
the year boxed his ears scolded him
nicely slapped him
say you eat it already we are in enough
trouble
now you come without shoes
because in germany in winter no shoes
means you may lose your feet
so she's angry about that in the next
station the boys and girls were
separated
after four years
after the war was over
she came out of the concentration camp
to find
17 members of her family including her
little brother
all had vanished
no records no sign of them they just
evaporated
at that time
the only thing that bothered her was
the last few things that she said to her
little brother
she loves her brother
but the last few things that she said to
him for such terrible things
it rang in her mind
and troubled her these are the last
things i told my brother and after that
i'm never going to see him he's gone
so she took a wow
if i speak to anybody in my life
i will speak in such a way if this is my
last word i will not regret
this one thing
transformed her life in such a way she
went on to united states she died in
2006
she did some phenomenal work built a
hospital
somewhere near
chicago i think
she lived a fruitful life
i'm saying
even if you put through the most
horrible situations
either you can come out using that
experience as a better human being
or you can use the experience to become
a horrible mess
so whenever something hurts you
there are two options
you can either become wounded
or you can become wise this is the
choice
the more things hurt you early on in
your life
the wiser you should have become isn't
it
but unfortunately most people become
wounded
this is simply because
they just need an excuse to turn their
own intelligence against themselves
that's all especially if the world
around you turns against you
is it not very very important that your
intelligence stands up for you around us
so many people will do so many things
that we don't like
yes or no
so many things in mumbai happening
things that we don't like are everyday
happening
but at least within you
only what you want should happen within
this isn't it
i cannot decide that only what i want
should happen with you
but i can definitely decide only what i
want must happen within me isn't it
if you
could decide
only what you want should happen within
you
would you choose anger
or joy
what's your choice please choose i'm
going to bless you
see
you want the highest level of
pleasantness for yourself isn't it
then why is such a thing not happening
as i said earlier
you never read the user's manual
how this functions has not been looked
at
do not go by the example of people who
came here a few few years earlier than
you
that no no my mother also was like that
my grandmother also was getting angry so
i am also getting angry
they should not be the leading lights of
your life i want you to look at it
your thought your emotion your body must
happen the way you want isn't it
if somebody else can decide what should
happen within you
this is ultimate slavery isn't it so
what happens around you maybe we can
decide but nobody should decide except
yourself what happens within you
if you decide
you would keep this in the high state of
pleasantness for sure
you wouldn't be battling with anger
it's not just about anger fear stress
tension don't address them separately
essentially your mind is not taking
instructions from you
why because you don't know where the
keyboard is
yet
we gave you a super computer
you do not know where where the keyboard
is so one day you did this something
worked another day you did this
something worked you know have you seen
people the radio doesn't work boom
and it works sometimes
that's not a technology that's chance
have you seen this
if something doesn't work people think
tupped up tough
it'll work and a lot of people are using
this for human beings also fear of
suffering
is not just about pain the fear of
suffering
is self-inflicted
nobody can cause mental pain to you it
is you
in reaction to something that happens
around you
that you cause pain to yourself
if you
have half your brain removed
[Music]
then you would see
you would be quite peaceful
right now people are going through
stress anxiety depression misery all
kinds of things
you can give it any number of exotic
names that you want but essentially
their intelligence is turned against
them that's all it is
once your intelligence is against you
there is no force on the planet or
anywhere which can save you
so the fundamental thing is
to bring this
that all the faculties that we have
should work for our well-being
right now our own body our own mind our
own emotions are working against us
this one thing has to be fixed this
happened
in the year
98-99
andrea garcia and boris becker played
three games
all
bodyspecker beat andrea garcia because
he had such a you know he was called
boom boom
because
boris becker was called boom boom
because of the service his serves were
so powerful there was no game every time
he will serve serve and finish the game
nobody returns the ball
so
andre agassi went back
and studied hundreds of hours of boris
becker's
serves
then he figured it out
then in the next
three years he played 11 games with him
and beat him on 10 of them
and i'll tell you what happened
after boris becker retired
they met in germany there's something
called the october fest in germany they
were there
and at that time they were together
and andre agassi thought okay anyway
he's retired now i can tell him because
this bothered body speaker big time
nobody can beat him but these guy's
getting at him so he told him see
i observed your videos continuously and
i figured out
that whenever you are serving the ball
towards the boundary line
boris becker if you know
when he's serving his tongue sticks out
a little bit
when he throws the ball up and comes
down his tongue sticks out said whenever
you're serving towards the
boundary line your tongue goes to the
left
when you're serving straight it comes
out straight
i observed this the moment your tongue
sticks out to the boundary line i was
already there every time taking the ball
so
boris becker literally fell off his
chair he couldn't believe this
and he said
any number of times i went home after
the matches and i told my wife he seems
to be reading my mind
but you've been reading my tongue
it's almost spoken
so
your opponent should be never unfamiliar
to you you must make him familiar you
must know him better than he knows
himself just to give a little bit of
context we saw the video sakuraji
running on himalayas playing football
playing cricket so in that context how
to keep yourself on the go all the time
on the cook
you don't have to be on the go all the
time
if life demands
people ask me so guru how are you active
like this because generally my schedule
is anywhere between 18 to 20 hours a day
seven days of the week 365 days non-stop
for many years it's going on
i'm
i'm complaining and the guy is clapping
about it
[Laughter]
so people keep asking how do you keep
yourself like this how do you do this
see
i'm essentially lazy
it's just that
the situation in the world demands
action
left to myself i would close my eyes and
simply sit
i'm made like this if i close my eyes i
can sit like this till i fall dead
really
i have really no need for action i'm not
trying to keep myself busy there's a lot
to be done so you're doing
people ask me sid guru what's your dream
what is your dream
i said my dream is the day i am
unemployed that's a great day because if
i am unemployed it simply means
everybody is doing fantastic
what more do you want dream fulfilled
so
action is not something that you decide
you just decide your intent
action the world will decide how much of
what
i am you know at these economic forums
instead i'm in the world economic forum
this guy
in front of the business schools in
harvard business school one professor
comes oh you're that amazing tree
planter
i said no i'm not a tree planter
he said no no you planted those millions
of this yes i did but i'm not a tree
planter
then what do you do
i said uh i make people flower
not plant trees but i'm planting trees
because the god trees are missing where
they should have been
where they should have been they are not
there
it's like this two men were working on
the street
one man is digging pits behind him
another man is coming and closing and
closing and going
somebody else was driving by
they saw this ridiculous activity
one guy digs the pit another guy closes
the pit
so they stopped and said hey what are
you doing here why are you guys working
like this one guy digging another
closing they said no no
the in-between guy has gone and leave
he's the tree planter
he's not there we're doing our work
so a lot of people are doing work like
i'm doing my work
you have no work on this planet if the
planet needs work if the world needs
work we will do it
otherwise why should i think this is my
work
so guru what's your mission it's no
mission i'm just fooling around a bit
because
you have no business
to have your own mission
life has its own mission
in some way if you can assist and serve
that that's about it
what is it that you have your own
mission are you some kind of a tyrant
all missionaries are tyrants in some way
unknowingly yes those who think they
have a mission
there is no mission what is needed you
do especially
when you study in a business school and
get certain competence to manage things
or create things
you must create what is needed
not create some rubbish and push it on
them
yes
yes or no
you must see how to make life better how
to solve situations which are
problematic to a whole lot of people you
must look for solutions and solutions
for the existing situations and of
course there are experts who go on
creating new problems
so you will never be short of problems
believe me
you just have to create solutions not go
on a mission mode
that's for mussolini what people are
generally
calling
as destiny
is essentially
what they end up creating unconsciously
when i say unconsciously
as you sit here right now
as everybody sits here right now
there is physical activity going on
within the system
there is mental process
there is emotional activity
and of course the life energies are
active
every moment
they are taking in hundreds of inputs
whether you're conscious or not
conscious
so if i ask you a question since this
morning from the time you woke up till
now
of these four dimensions of activity
how much have you conducted consciously
what percentage do you think
few things
how much percentage do you think
25 percent
you are very generous man
it's well below one percent
if you walk from there to there
there will be 25 different kind of
smells that you're not conscious of that
the body registers and records
there are
100 different kinds of sounds that the
body registers
that you are not conscious of
like this throughout the day and night
in wakefulness and sleep this is
happening
when you are only conscious of less than
one percent of your activity
definitely life will look like an
accident
hello
when 99 of the things that you're doing
you're doing unconsciously
definitely life look will look
accidental
if the accident
see it just so happened
somebody fell off on the street and had
a brain injury after that suddenly
they started working their mathematics
in a wonderful way
but that was only one
a thousand other people who cracked
their skull
never recovered from that or they died
or those who lived on
lived on much diminished
so
being accidentally
fortunate
is not the way to exist
so whenever
a pleasant accident happens we say it's
destiny
some of you even say god
doing things to me
when did you make a partnership with him
i don't know
so
shall i tell you a story okay
this happened
sherlock holmes you know sherlock holmes
and watson
went out camping
and
early
morning 3 30 am
sherlock holmes
nudged virtually
he opened his eyes what
what do you see he asked
well i see a clear sky and stars
what does it mean to you
he said well
that means tomorrow is going to be a
wonderful sunny day
then he asked what does it mean to you
is that it means
someone has stolen our tent
[Laughter]
so
we don't know what went missing
and something may fall here and there by
chance but that's not the way life works
if a human being doesn't take it upon
himself
or herself to make their own destiny
they are still having an evolutionary
problem
that is
they are still
not yet fully there
because being human means this
that we can conduct our life consciously
being human means this
that we can craft our life the way we
want
but this destiny business
is a good insurance to handle your
failure
whenever you fail
destiny
it's god's will just because somebody is
successful this doesn't mean they've
figured out everything this doesn't mean
they're at ease with life this doesn't
mean
their life is in some way fulfilled no
because today our idea of success is
just doing little better than somebody
else
you doing little better than somebody
else means
and you're very happy about that
what it means is you're actually
enjoying other people's failures
if somebody enjoys another person's
failure or i call that sickness not
success what do you call it hello
[Music]
i enjoy that you failed
this is sickness this is not success
isn't it
unfortunately this is how you're going
this is the reason why
human potential is not unleashed
because if you're racing with a lame
person
you're just happy you're one step ahead
of him
only when you meet mr bolt
you understand who the hell you are
yes
till then you think you are a great
runner because other person doesn't have
legs you did this activity where to get
us awake and energized you had us close
our eyes and you counted the three and
then we had to yell
lose our inhibitions and and let it all
out
and that idea of kind of losing control
and losing inhibitions for me personally
has actually been uh
a challenge
and i was hoping to get your perspective
uh i have
never done drugs because i don't want to
lose control i fight roller coasters
because i don't like losing control of
the body all this
i i i'm i'm excited for your perspective
i don't know why it uh it came up
because last night i did my best but
it's always been um
a challenger struggle for me and i'm
just curious to get your perspective
nature has imposed
substantial
amount of
restrictions
on life
you can just zoom out into the space
there is enough restrictions
you don't have to invent your own
restrictions on top of it
so if you invent your own restrictions
slowly over a period of time you become
a constipated life
that means
life won't happen easy
it happens in small
happenings so being in a state of
abandon
not out of
control being in a state of abandoned
means
all the stops that you have put on
yourself you pulled it off
nature stops are still there
there for your safety and your
well-being
but why are you imposing stops
there's
enough gravity is holding you down
that's bad enough
now you want to hold yourself down why
because fear
what is the fear about
the fear is always about
if i do this i may suffer so that is a
fundamental of my work
to bring you to your place where there's
no fear of suffering as a child
did you blow soap bubbles
soap bubbles
so when you blew soap bubbles
have you seen
somebody got this big bubble you got
only this big bubble
we must hold our breath and leave it
slow then we'd get a bit bubble
everything
everybody had air in the lungs but
somebody got a big bubble somebody got a
small bubble
what is this about
see when it comes to
body this is my body that is your body
100 clear no confusion about this isn't
it this is my body that is your body
this is my mind that is your mind
but when it comes to life
there is no such thing as my life and
your life
this is a living
cosmos how much life will you capture
within your system will determine
the size and scope of your life
somebody got a big bubble
somebody else got a small bottle poop it
went off
you cannot identify
where is my air and where is your air
isn't it
so similarly when it comes to life there
is no such thing as my life and your
life but distinctly my body and your
body my mind and your mind but know my
life and your life there is life
abundant life this is a living cosmos
how much life will you capture
within yourself
will determine the scope and range of
your life
what one person can do
in 100 years somebody may do it in 10
years
because of the sheer intensity of life
when i say intensity of life it may
translate in many different ways
see
there are times for example certain
businesses have grown
let us say
uh some business like uh you know in the
united states this become a fad
within three years somebody's billions
of dollars of worth of business
let us say microsoft has grown or
facebook has grown or something like
this has grown
this is largely because of technological
breakthroughs and somebody writes that
technology
at another time that would not have
happened
so that is different
but
if you want to create something
really large
really significant large or small is not
the point significance
then you need intensity of life
one thing is the scale of life that you
capture
there are this is what i said earlier
when i said yoga obliterating in
boundaries of your individuality means
in a way you are allowing universe to
invade you
when universe is not against you but it
invades you or it's a part of you
then
you have abundance of life
when you have abundance of life
you will not hesitate to share
when you share big time your life with
everybody else
people
will naturally value it immensely
because everybody is trying to hold it
somebody is willing to share it
so naturally there will be a big upsurge
around you
this will lead to many things
this will make many friends and many
enemies
a lot of people whom you have never met
they are your own enemies but you don't
know why
you never met them you never had a word
with them but they are swearing that i
am his enemy i don't know why
but it goes on in the world
so when we talk about how so much can be
done in a short span of time
it's not a short span of time it's 37
years
incessant work seven days of the week
20 hours a day almost for 25 years
more than 25 years
on an average i slept only for two and a
half hours a day
not deprived of sleep
just kept my life energy so intense
that sleep was not even an issue
there are times when i've gone without
sleep for three days four days full
scale working
not because you're
on some kind of a drug and
not sleeping
simply because of the intensity of
purpose and commitment to what you're
doing
today i can proudly say i have created
thousands of people around me
all of them have gotten crazy like that
they all beginning to work like this
most of them you don't know when they
will sleep when they will wake up on on
seven days of the week
no holidays no vacations but everybody
is joyful
if you come to the yoga center and see
you will see the most joyful faces
but they've never been on a vacation
they don't own a damn thing they don't
have money in their pockets but they're
just joyful
because
drunk with life
literally
[Music]
to see the one-on-one i did about karma
with sadguru check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there this is like
banging your head on a wall which is not
going to break anyway it's your head
which will break
what you can change you do not change
what you can craft you do not do it
because all your energy goes into